as if Batman didn't have enough problems
he's now facing accusations of thievery
since camera test footage of star Robert
Pattinson suited up for writer director
Matt Reeves as the Batman was made
public last week some bands have been
taken to social media to pan the new
getup it's not DC diehards that are
doing most of the dissing though it's
Marvel fans who seemed to think that
baton since mask bears a little too much
of a resemblance to that worn by the
devil of Hell's Kitchen in the Netflix
series daredevil it doesn't help that
the footage was absolutely bathed in a
candy apple red glow which has the
effect of making the dark night suit
look as if it's been dyed daredevil red
and is also reminiscent of the Netflix
series opening credits of course the
camera test footage didn't give us a
head-to-toe gander at the new bat suit
it mostly lingered on the chest piece
along with the mask and cowl
it never does show us Bruce Wayne's bat
ears which are typically set much
further back from the forehead than
Daredevils trademark horns so the
similarity between the new bat suit and
Daredevils duds might not be quite so
pronounced once we get a full color
top-to-bottom peek it's tough to argue
though that the mask baton sin is
sporting with its shaped Brown nose
guard and opening from the mouth and
chin that's cut nearly all the way back
to the temple doesn't look pretty
daredevil ask a strong contingent of
Marvel fans came out on Twitter to jeer
at the new bat suit pretty much
immediately after the test footage was
released more than a few fans just
angrily pointed out the resemblance like
this user who tweeted I mean did they
even try these questions
our vital ones while others at least had
a sense of humor about the whole thing
like this user who tweeted if daredevil
could see the Batman right now he would
be pissed as always though there were a
few voices of reason amid the chorus of
boos deciding to go ahead and address
every criticism thus far leveled at
patent since Caped Crusader 1 user wrote
dear people still upset about the new
Batman the suit and cowl is fine yes
that looked like daredevil it's not just
because he's in red light it's the shape
of the cowl Robert Pattinson has other
roles aside from twilight watch the
lighthouse he doesn't need to be buff
we've been saying ever since a casting
was announced that Pattinson is a
criminally underrated actor who is going
to make an absolutely fantastic Batman
need proof first there's the 2017 crime
drama goodtime which stars Pattinson as
a bank robber desperately trying to
gather funds to get a simple-minded
brother out of prison the flick was
directed by the safty brothers who
turned in one of the sharpest thrillers
in recent memory with last year's uncut
gems Pattinson performance a good time
has been hailed by critics as both
brilliant and about as far from edward
cullen as you can get
next we direct you to 2018 s highlight a
sci-fi drama from acclaimed French
director Claire Denis Pattinson stars as
a condemned prisoner aboard a deep space
mission bound for a black hole and the
movies crazy nonlinear narrative is
absolutely anchored by his committed
performance
speaking of committed performances you'd
also do well to follow the advice of the
Twitterer above and watched the
lighthouse in which Pattinson totally
holds his own in what is essentially a
two man acting showcase opposite the
great Willem Dafoe all of the above
movies are far from your typical
Hollywood fare and they all demonstrate
that Pattinson is an actor of impressive
range who is more than capable of
delivering an interesting new take on
Bruce Wayne as for that daredevil II
Cowell let's just reserve judgment until
we see some actual non test footage
shall we check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]